you know he gets the most hate drake
drake yeah
drake wins but he does but online he's
you're saying i'm kind of like drake
wait
you're the jewish drake i'm saying drake
might be jewish well i'm saying both
y'all are like drake yeah
drake is you guys together he's blind
yeah you're cool right now i admit it
you're cooler than me dude this is like
heaven yeah this is like
dividing drake we could hold hands and
then
i think this would be the closest we
were going to get to having drake on the
show
that's why we brought you guys here
well who's the thing inside let's just
get that out no man i'm the rapper
all right i'll sing okay hell yeah okay
so you're the rap insider you're the
second son
he's marvin's room i'm 4 p.m in dallas
oh dang running i don't know the
reference i don't understand it well
it's a drake song
oh that's fine well 6 p.m in new york i
don't listen around this tiger
dang man man we got a real [ __ ] fest up
in here dude
i know kind of i i said i
i said to brendan i said hey brenden
let's get to let's try some get some
different people in
and the culture corner you get more men
man dude
we look like a boy band no direction
look at your glasses the glasses
are those gucci glasses uh are they what
are those
yeah they're gucci be cool all right
they're cool though britney
brennan the accountant for like a male
sex trafficking group
you look like a guy that comes and tells
people if rainbows are uh
to uh [ __ ]
i'm not at your outfit today though doug
oh you look at the guy
that comes in here shows up and tells if
rainbows are to specifications or not
you're like yeah this rainbow chicks
yeah yeah i'm gonna just do the drake ad
live every time y'all say something like
yeah
is that what jake does yeah he does does
he yeah yeah he does that
yeah he totally does that i am not i'm
not not a drake fan but i don't know
enough about him i have to read up on
him a little
his music is fantastic you know he's a
child actor
oh yeah he didn't grow up like thug he
grew up like
he was a child well i remember yeah his
one of his lyrics in the beginning was
like he barred his uncle car that was
like the toughest thing that had
happened to him
and he had it back late and go to the
back yeah and then he parked the
rolls-royce in the driver
degrassi and he was in a wheelchair on
the show of course he was pissed jimmy
he was jimmy on the ground oh he's
playing handicapped he's playing
handicapped
he's a basketball player they shot him
in the hallway that's right in his back
right
yeah in his back yep jimmy and then he
did he's he's in a wheelchair
and then he has the same late legs as
malik wait what time wait wait wait wait
a minute
wait i got you know what you can feel
them i got good hips though you do i got
bad legs oh yeah
legs skinny legs sorry oh really that's
like a um
one of those english bulldog i think
that they're like that or no uh
uh what's that australian shepherd well
they have little skinny legs
they got bad legs yeah yeah can you look
that up australian shepherd
dysplasia hip dysplasia i don't think
that no
those dogs are super athletic there you
go
oh yeah oh yeah i could beat that i
could be cool yeah i got
you right there that's drake that's the
dog drake right there
[Music]